[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is be a
subscriber like and comment
hey guys welcome to the final game of
thrones review
the series finale just ended and here we
are breaking it down
not gonna lie i'm disappointed big time
and i'm sure most of you guys are as
well
this is not the same show we have all
fallen in love with the better street
ending we've been promised turned out to
be just better
i honestly don't know what was sweet
about this ending
well yes it was nice to see john reunite
with ghost i guess
and yes i get it the starks have won at
the end but i don't like the progression
and execution of all of this
not one bit the starks you know are
these good guys honest and fair
not some schemers plotting behind the
back of people who saved them
if not for daniel the starks including
jon as well would not be alive at this
point
if danny was not so good-hearted and if
she was this mad queen all along
she would not go north and help the
stars defend their ancestral home and
kingdom
but she did she helped them and she
saved them she lost big portion of
armies and friends in the process
and what did she get in return the
starks forming an ultimate plan how to
make her mad
get her kill them win the game of
thrones bran stark is the ultimate
villain
littlefinger and varys were right when
they said knowledge is power
and the one with most knowledge bran
vince bryan knows everything that's
happened
everything that's happening and
everything that will happen
the only use of him against the night
king was giving arya the valyrian steel
dagger
which he knew arya would later use to
kill the night king in the game of
thrones among the living though brain
was as useless as he can get
and now we know why was that bran had
the plan all along
and it was him ending up on the armed
round brennan has been manipulating
events throughout the entire season 8
that would get him to this point brain
is the final villain of the story in my
opinion
brent manipulated sam into telling john
the truth knowing sam would turn john
against danny
since the moment he told him to tell
john the truth was pretty much a few
minutes after he found out danny burned
his father and brother
brain already knew what was jean going
to do he's going to tell the truth to
his family
and bring a new sense that did not like
dany and she's a little finger student
he knew sansa would start scheming to
throw dany by using jon's claim
and he knew that this way the truth
behind john's shoe parentage and claim
would spread
bran says to sam to tell the truth to
john john tells the truth to his family
sansa tells it to tirion tyrion tells it
where is some various same forms sold
the seven kingdoms
the truth spreads then his own advisor
starts plotting behind her back
then he grows more paranoid and
ultimately turns mad and kills the
innocent
john is then left with no choice but to
kill her and john himself must be
punished for this
old event's brain manipulated led to the
outcome he's been working on this entire
season
bran stark becomes the king of the seven
kingdoms brain the one with the most
knowledge and does the most power wins
the game of thrones
he was behind everything that happened
in season 8. not so bad of an ending
after all
if it was well written and if bran had
any other line then i don't want
anything really
i can't beat the lord winner fell on the
3a raven now and if the execution was
not so terrible
but unfortunately it was and almost no
one can say this ending was satisfying
it was bitter and disappointing anyways
let's get back to the beginning of an
episode
john davos and tyrion are walking
through the aftermath of the battle of
king's landing
they will see the horror dennis dunton
king's landing and all the innocent
truly dreadful shots this serves as some
kind of a justification for dennis dead
that's coming a bit later
dany is the mad queen and jon realizes
varys was right after all
just when i think that a few seasons
back dany locked up her dragon
because jogan burned one single child
only to then use drogon to kill hundreds
of thousands
makes me realize how badly the
showrunners butchered denzerk in the
final season
stan is who then is ultimately the
biggest victim of the bad writing
it's not danny becoming the mad queen
that upsets me it's how we got there and
how she's become one
a rushed and inconsistent mess as i
already said in my danny video
tormund's statement what kind of a
person rides a dragon a madman or king
did strike me as some kind of a
foreshadow for what's to come
dany being the mad one and jon being the
true king
that's not enough danny did say two
times in earlier season how she's going
to take back what's hers with firing
blood
and i'd be okay with that if dany in
season 7 when she arrived to instantly
attack king's landing
did what she did in last episode and
fulfilled her words
but she didn't and she promised to lance
their soldiers that that's not her
but cersei who destroys some burnt
cities and kills the innocent
she said she's come to save them then in
season 8 episode 3 she indeed saves
westeros with her armies and dragons
only to two episodes later used the same
army center dragon to destroy the
capital of westeros
killing hundreds of thousands civilians
danny was made a villain in one single
episode
and there was no real build up for this
in the books yes on the show no
anyways as they walk through the ruins
they come across denny's armies
commanded by grey worm
who trapped remaining lancer soldiers
and are about to kill them
then he commanded her armies to kill
every remaining enemy soldier
which upsets jon and tyrion jump leads
greyworm to stop this madness
but greyworm tells them it's the queen's
orders and kills them
later jon sees danny and drogon behind
her and as she walks down the stairs
jones shadow makes denny look like she
has giant wings
such a weird scene but this is a nice
call back to season 7 and dennis
conversation with elena when she said
danny to be a dragon
and now she truly is the dragon taking
what's hers with fire and blood
then he gives a speech to her armies she
says to the cheering the threaky and
disciplined and sully that they just
freed the people from king's landing
and the new goal is freeing the rest of
the world freeing all the slaves
then he turns to tyrion and tells him he
committed treason
tyrion tells her that she killed
thousands of innocent people and he
takes off the hand's spin and throws it
then it sends him to prison this is not
coming as a surprise
since tyrion did extremely good job
identifying himself to the unsolid
guards before freeing jaime
and then he did warn tyrion in the
beginning of episode 5 that if he ever
fails her again
it would be his last while imprisoned
tyrion tries to convince jon to turn on
dany
his family will never be saved because
it threatens danny's legitimacy
john is convinced by tyrion that his
family will never be safe
because he represents a threat to her
rule jean goes to see dany and she is
sitting on the iron throne alone
and jon tells her that she needs to stop
this madness then he tells john that
she's doing it for the people
and that's when jon sees danny is indeed
mad and must be stopped
jumper tends to understand her when her
guard is down he stabs her
that's then his third prophesied
betrayal betrayal for love
basically john gives danny one last
chance trying to talk to her to see if
she realizes what she's done is a huge
mistake and crime
then it justifies her actions and that's
when jaime realized there's no turning
back
she is this mad queen and a huge threat
to westeros having already destroyed one
great city
and hundreds of thousands innocent
people and john is left with no choice
but to kill her
one thing i kept repeating throughout my
videos the meaning of denny's visions
came true
i was constantly saying that this
particular dane's vision from the
undying was foreshadowing this all along
then he wins the armed throne and
becomes queen of ashes that are covering
it
but she will not be able to ever sit on
it or at least not for long
because jon will have to put an end to
her madness whereupon she'll join drogo
and her son on the other world
that's exactly what happened after
dany's skill jones comes and is standing
over her body
and he burns her melts the arm throne
and carries her away
one would think that drogon would rip
jon apart for killing his mother
or burn the entire king's landing to the
ground but no
jorgen picks her up and leaves i'm also
surprised that grey worm with his
unsullied and dothraki did not kill jon
on sight
but instead took him for a fair trial i
don't know if that's just me but just
the thought of the unsolid
not seeking revenge over their killed
queens sounds ridiculous
if someone asked me what would dany's
armies and dragons do to the person
city in the entire continent if she was
to be killed i'd say that pillage burn
and kill everyone
especially the dothraki all of them are
her blood writers
and that's their duty let me remind you
that back in season 6 upon winning
dothraki to her side
then reminds them that she has yet to
select her three bloodriders
as all the cults have done before her
she then declares that she's not a call
and selects the entire calazar her blood
writers
the title bloodrider carries great
prestige within a counselor
if a call is skilled blood rioters
avenge him once done they can move on
and not before
now danny skill then she doesn't have 3
blood writers but thousands of them and
none seek revenge
none of them seek to fulfill their duty
as a blood writer once again writing on
point
grey worm has tyrion and john as his
prisoners the council led by sansa tells
grey worm to release jon back to them
but he refuses tyrion is in front of the
council
and as a prisoner of grey worm he is not
making decision he is content with being
a prisoner
he makes suggestions only that centerian
says that the new king or queen should
decide what
happens to jon sam suggests a democratic
vote for the new king
tyrion calls that idea stupid the
council votes and decides bryce should
be the king
bram picks tyrion as his hand tyrion
tells jon that his punishment is going
back to the wall and joined the night's
watch
tyrion said greyworm wanted him dead and
sends someone a name back home
so nobody is getting what they want it's
a fair compromise
greyworm accepts jon's punishment he
doesn't bend the knee
leaves for his troops send the tracking
on ships to free slave cities
they showed tyrion leading the council
john says goodbye to sansa and arya
maria tells them she is not going back
home she is going to explore whatever is
best of westeros because there is where
no one has been
the final scene is a closing montage
you'll see aria on a ship
sensor ruling winner fell and john goes
stormwind and a bunch of wildlings
leaving the wall and heading north
what was the point of the entire the
lone wolf dies but the pax survives
slime from season 7.
brands at king's landing sansa and
winterfell aria leaves westeros and jon
goes beyond the wall
all of them now are the lone wolves i
also find it ridiculous that bram was
chosen as a new king
bran might be this soulsting 3 at raven
and jon might have killed dany
but it doesn't matter he is their
rightful king
for all they know danny deserved the
throne and jon had to kill her to take
what's his by his right
they would all vote for jon snow to beat
their king if the show had any sense
left
the saw very long evaded bittersweet
ending and zhang killing dany and going
beyond the wall
while brain stark is democratically
chosen as the new king of the seven
kingdoms
is it better that jon kills dany or is
it bitter that bran becomes the king
what's exactly sweet about ascending i
don't think the ending is necessarily
bad as in fact it's how george armand's
books will also end
as i said multiple times that the ending
will be the same but the journey to get
there will be quite different
and the journey is exactly what was so
disappointing here
danny going mad bran becoming the king
and everything else could have been
written so that all of this would make
sense
instead they got rushed and poorly
written season where ending is nowhere
near bittersweet
only bitter brain ended up the king the
kid who refused lordship of winterfell
because he is the three-year-old raven
now
but then he accepts to be the king of
the seven kingdoms
to make the stark swing and brain end up
on the throne the showrunners made dany
mad in just one episode so jon could
kill her
this faden is obviously dead and cannot
be the queen while jon takes the black
for killing her
which makes him no longer a legitimate
heir to the throne
as i explained in the beginning of this
video bran stark is the ultimate villain
of game of thrones
he is the reason danny turned mad and
jon had to kill her he manipulated all
the season 8 events
everything so he could become this next
king of the seven kingdoms
bran stark won game of thrones thanks to
the power of knowledge
while as itself might not sound such bad
of an ending as i already said the
execution was very poorly written
and all the emotion descending could
have achiness is disappointment
i don't like it but hopefully you guys
do and hopefully you're not as
disappointed as much as i am
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace